bruno retailleau le nouveau président du
groupe ump au sénat est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec dailymotion et avec l'
agence france-presse représenter ce soir
par guillaume daudin bien avec lui tout
à l'heure nous parlerons de la
compétition qui s'aiguisent à l'ump en
vue de 2017 et puis nous ferons plus
ample connaissance avec vous à la fin de
ce journal est avec perrine tarneaud
votre vos combats votre parcours un
engagement d'ailleurs tout récent à
l'ump on verra ça donc avec perrine tout
à l'heure d'abord bruno retailleau les
nouvelles pistes d'économies pour les
allocations familiales il y aura une
modulation partiel c'est la piste donc
été retenu par les députés ps en accord
semble-t-il avec le gouvernement ainsi
la fin de la majoration à partir de 15
ans pour les enfants des ménages les
plus aisés comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à ce que la gauche présente
comme une mesure de justice et d'équité
moi je ne comprends pas du tout cette
obsession anti famille de la gauche ça
me dépasse dès qu'il faut des mesures
c'est sûr les familles qu'on tape on
ad'abord matraquer fiscalement les
familles et désormais on voudrait les
étrangler ce que je voudrais dire bien
sûr financièrement ce que je voudrais
dire très simplement c'est que le
déficit de la branche famille il est dû
à une chose c'est que sa branche famille
est ponctionnée hauteur de plus de 4
milliards d'euros pour les régimes de
retraite première chose deuxième chose
s'il ya quelque chose qui fonctionne
bien en france c'est justement la
politique familiale qui nous permet
d'avoir une natalité une démographie qui
est dynamique n'oublions jamais que ce
qu'on appelle la croissance potentielle
dépend de la démographie de demain et
l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui commence à
l'éprouver parce qu' elle n'a pas le
même taux de natalité est donc on a un
indicateur qui fonctionne bien en france
la natalité et on veut y mettre fin je
trouve que c'est extrêmement grave c'est
la fin de la politique avec une
dimension universelle de la famille on
confond de choses on confond une
politique redistributive qui est par
essence la politique fiscale avec une
autre politique et la politique
familiale mais je peux vous assurer que
sur le plan de l'emploi sur le plan
économique ce sera catastrophe mais en
elle en avait la ministre de la santé
marisol touraine à votre place et c il
ya quinze jours elle disait qu'elle ne
voulait pas croire qu'on faisait des
enfants dans notre pays pour les
prestations sociales albert que nous est
sûr que nous disait qu'elle ça n'aurait
aucune incidence sur la natalité bien
sûr que non mais il s'agit à niveau de
vie comparable
quand vous avez deux familles qui ont
l'une qui ont qu un enfant ou l'autre
qui vont avoir trois enfants l'une qui a
plusieurs enfants va contribuer par
exemple au régime de répartition pour
les retraites et c'est normal elle va
subir une baisse de niveau de vie c'est
normal que la politique familiale puisse
compenser cette baisse de niveau de vie
c'est un problème d'utilité publique et
j'ajoute politiquement que
malheureusement notre pacte républicain
c'est aussi la politique familiale
pourquoi parce que c'est le front
populaire michel grossiord qui inventent
les allocations familiales c'est général
de gaulle qui invente le quotient
familial
donc il ya un consensus qui se fait sur
la famille aujourd'hui la gauche
brouille les repères casse les consensus
divise les français et en plus amène
l'économie française dans le trou noir
sur cette mesure la wii est une mesure
terrible sur le plan économique sur le
plan de la justice familiale c'est une
mesure anti justice vraiment est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on assassine ont
massacré la politique familiale en
voulant faire 700 millions d'économies
alors que le budget global beda la
natalité ses 60 milliards
mais pourquoi vouloir faire des
économies sur la famille pourquoi
vouloir faire des économies sur un
secteur qui fonctionne voilà il ya tant
d'autres économies et on attend du
gouvernement qu'il fasse des vraies
économies notamment de politique
structurelle il ne les fait pas alors
effectivement le besoin d'économies il
est criant dans tous les secteurs bruno
retailleau la droite d'ailleurs promet
de faire deux fois mieux que le
gouvernement dans le bras de fer
il est déjà amorcée d'ailleurs entre
paris et bruxelles sur le budget parce
que vous donnerez donc raison à
bruxelles
je suis français mais ce que je veux
simplement dire au gouvernement c'est
que pour tenir son rang à bruxelles il
faut tenir ses comptes en france mais là
c'est une règle tout sépare et affiche
sa confiance face à bruxelles le
gouvernement a tort il a tort le
problème c'est que le gouvernement a
déjà pris des engagements françois
hollande souvenez-vous après plusieurs
engagements d'abord 2013 ensuite 2015
pour ramener les déficits à 3% est
extraordinaire c'est la première fois
depuis la crise des années 2008 2010
2009 le déficit en france cette année
soit supérieur au déficit 2013 c'est
catastrophique pour la crédibilité
française donc je ne donne ni tort à
bruxelles je ne donne pas raison
gouvernement français quand on prend des
engagements accord on les tient on les
tient pas pour bruxelles on les tient
pour remettre en ordre les comptes
français parce que si on ne les remet
pas en ordre on va dépendre de plus en
plus d'investisseurs notamment étrangers
qui détiennent notre dette et ont
vertement fragiliser la france justement
françois fillon qui à votre soutien a
évoqué récemment le risque d'un accident
financier majeur pour notre pays qu'est
ce qu'il a voulu dire il veut il parler
des taux d'intérêt heureusement il ya je
me suis draghi mène une politique est
extrêmement mobile extrêmement réactive
à la tête de la banque centrale
européenne et les taux sont très bas
pourquoi les taux sont bas parce qu'il
ya cette politique européenne mais aussi
parce que il ya une déprime et quand il
ya peu de croissance en règle générale
les taux sont bas simplement ce que
voulait dire françois fillon c'est que
si jamais demain les taux augmentait
d'un point ça se répercuterait sur la
première année de 2 milliards 4
milliards on entrerait dans une spirale
grecque et ce serait très difficile à
maîtriser heureusement nous n'en sommes
pas là heureusement mais le moment de la
catastrophe
approche si le gouvernement français
continue de trahir ses engagements est
ce que en même temps vous reconnaissez
qu'il faut savoir ne pas aller trop loin
en matière d'économie parce que certains
économistes
disque on pourrait s'enfoncer un peu
plus dans la récession
écoutez sur ce débat je pense qu'il faut
avoir les idées claires
ce que fait aujourd'hui le gouvernement
c'est des coups de rabot c'est une
politique à la petite semaine il n'y a
aucune vision d'ensemble il n'y a pas de
politique structurelle aujourd'hui il
faut changer de cadre par exemple on
sait parfaitement que pour faire des
économies il faudra toucher à la masse
salariale de l'état pour avoir moins de
fonctionnaires il faudra pouvoir les
payer sans doute mieux mais ne pas les
remplacer tous pour le départ à la
retraite et pour le faire il fracasse et
je suis désolé la politique des 35
heures y compris dans la fonction
publique alors vous ne mentionnez pas
les collectivités locales si je
retailleau alors c'est parce qu'elles
sont elles se font encore épinglé
aujourd'hui par la cour des comptes a
avec des dépenses de fonctionnement qui
ne cessent d'augmenter alors un les
collectivités locales doivent aussi être
associé à la fort à l'effort d'économie
générale ça nous passe avec la baisse
des dotations de choc c'est ce qui se
passe avec la baisse dans les yeux en
attendait simplement simplement on en a
marre que l'état au moment même où il
nous demande de faire des économies se
défausse sur nous je prends un exemple
et rythmes scolaires c'est paris qui
décide et c'est les collectivités en bas
qui paye et cet exemple là je peux le x
10 michel grossiord donc moi je dis
chiche pour des économies alors que
l'état arrête de nous transférer des
charges des nouvelles dépenses ce que je
voudrais dire aussi c'est que des
effectifs de fonctionnaires mais les
collectivités locales n'ont cessé
d'embaucher c'est ce que dénonce la cour
des comptes issus et notamment sur le
blog e intercommunalités et communes
donc je pense qu'il ya des efforts à
faire je pense que l'eia certaines
collectivités ou les fonctionnaires ils
sont en dessous de 35 heures ça n'est
pas normal je pense que cette petite
cette politique 35 heures il fera la
revoir ce que je veux dire quand même
par les collectivités c'est que les
collectivités n'ont pas la même dette
que l'état pourquoi parce que nous avons
la règle d'or nous avons nous une
interdiction écoutez moi bien
d'emprunter pour financer des dépenses
de fonctionnement c'est à dire que notre
dette et de la bonne date c'est celle
qui finance de l'investissement si
demain si demain avec la baisse des
dotations il ya plus d'investissements
des collectivités en france il y aura
plus du tout d'investissement public ce
sera moins d'emplois ce sera plus de
chômage c'est clair alors question
faut-il réformer l'assurance chômage des
indemnités moins généreuse moins
longtemps est ce que par exemple pour
parler franchement plus clairement vous
êtes sur la ligne valls macron non parce
que si l'on voit la ligne valls macro et
unis ont déclaré pour une réforme de
l'assurance chômage ils ont tout voir
ils sont au gouvernement n'attend pas
d'eux on attend on n'attend pas d'eux
qu'ils s'expriment qu'ils fassent des
déclarations on attend d'eux des actes
qu'ils agissent bien sûr moi je suis je
pense qu'il ya une forme de préférence
française pour le chômage de masse ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que il ya un
double paradoxe qui est insupportable
d'un côté il ya des gens qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi et ils veulent travailler
qu'on ne nous fasse pas croire que ce
sont tous des assistés c'est faux il ya
des brebis galeuses il faut le voir il
faut les sanctionner bien et de l'autre
côté paradoxe c'est que il ya des
centaines de milliers d'emplois je sais
dans mon département qu'il n'arrive pas
à trouver des chômeurs fin des gens pour
parce que ils sont pas suffisamment
qualifiés et c'est donc je pense qu'il
faudra sans doute revoir les modalités
d'indemnisation les modalités d'accès
etc surtout il faut transformer les
dépenses passives d'indemnisation en
dépenses active et notamment pour former
justement les chômeurs parce que c'est
que là en matière de formation il ya
déjà une enveloppe
de 20 milliards et c'est ceux qui sont
les mieux formés qui en bénéficient
c'est que j'avais ce débat à droite
entre le chef de l'état qui dit réformer
oui mais peut-être plus tard pour
certaines mesures comme l'assurance
celle ci voulait pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya des couacs permanent
avant monsieur montebourg c'était un
quad par mois monsieur macron c'est un
couac par semaine quant à mme royal à
chacune de ses phrases pratiquement ça
vient des couacs on parlera sans doute
de l'écotaxe tout simplement parce que
on a un chef de l'état qui est sans
boussole qui n'a pas de cas qui louvoie
en permanence donc ses ministres sont
servis d'une bactérie fication de culte
ni remaniement départ de monsieur
montebourg notamment non il ya cette
politique de l'offre mais elle est pour
l'instant en paroles et en attend les
actes et ses multiples couacs c'est tout
simplement parce que il ya des zigzags
il ya un louvoiements et je pense que
les ministres sont souvent perdus et
l'abandon de l'écotaxe justement c'est
un quoique peut aussi recelant vous la
baronne et quand vous vous rendez compte
que ça va coûter entre 1 et 2 milliards
aux français j'espère j'espère ce sera
pas le ménage qui vont payer puisque on
a deux centimes de plus pour le gazole
qui vont s'ajouter à la taxe carbone qui
était une taxe de 2 centimes aussi mais
c'est profit nos sociétés d'autoroutes
mais manifestement c'est compliqué elle
a été recadrée des sur ségolène royal et
notamment l été recadré par le premier
ministre sur la gratuité d auto tel
week-end vous regardez c'était une idée
évidemment qui avait tout pour plaire
faut-il en rire en sourire ou en pleurer
un mot sur un texte qui fait consensus
maintenant bruno retailleau cci le
bientôt arrivé d'ailleurs au sénat et
vous allez devant prononcer sur les
mesures pour contrôler embrigadement et
le départ des djihadistes française
qu'il faut aller plus loin dans ses
mesures présentées par le ministre
d'intérieur et aller vers une justice
d'exception comme l'a demandé par
exemple xavier bertrand qui pense aux
djihadistes qui sont de retour et qui
évidemment sont tous lourd de danger moi
en tout cas je pense qu'il faut la plus
grande fermeté mais il doit y avoir
toujours un équilibre entre les libertés
publiques et vous savez que le sénat est
très attaché à la promotion des libertés
publiques
mais en même temps il faut des
dispositifs qui soit efficace simplement
ce n'est pas avec ce texte qu'on va
résoudre le problème il ya un problème
qui est posé d'intégration et même
d'assimilation pour ces générations à la
culture française comment est ce que
vous comprenez ce que vous analysez
cette séduction effectivement chez
certains bailleurs il ya beaucoup de
convertis on le voit un parmi eux pour
un engagement islamique si loin de des
valeurs c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
vous avez gt gt un des tout premiers
parlementaires à me rendre en irak à
erbil c'était au mois d'août et j'ai
recueilli un certain nombre de
témoignages qui était poignant de
chrétiens de iasi dit quand on pense que
l'état islamique vent comme esclave pour
250 $ au marché de mossoul des jeunes
femmes quand on pense aux exactions
crucifixion décapitation est lente
ration de femme enceinte mais comment
comment peut-on en france avoir une
génération qui soit obnubilé par par
cette violence par cette barbarie sur ce
qu'est la question mais on n'avait pas
de contrer la compréhension j'essaie de
mettre certains évoquent des experts ou
même des stellistes de l'onu est en
cause c'est le problème une conséquence
de l'exclusion sociale
non non j'ai écouté c'est pas un prêtre
d'exclusion sociale il ya heureusement
des gens qui sont en difficulté et qui
n'adoptent pas des thèmes aussi radicaux
ce n'est pas possible je pense que il ya
le problème de la politique de migration
schengen au niveau européen en france
une politique d'assimilation à faire un
problème une réforme droit d'asie
mutation c'est un long terme souvent
controversial sur l'austérité on préfère
intégration pourquoi l'intégration parce
que l'intégration ça débouche souvent
sur le communautarisme et bien je pense
qu'il faut faire aimer à ces jeunes la
république française la notion d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes les
femmes sont égales aux hommes on ne peut
pas transiger là dessus on ne peut pas
faire cohabiter une culture qui serait
intégré mais qui conserverait cette
norme là c'est pas possible la
fraternité aussi c'est important la
liberté voilà je pense que la simulation
de ses valeurs elle est fondamentale
c'est la conception même de la
république aurait simplement dire que la
république française c'est quoi ce n'est
pas la couleur de peau ce n'est pas la
confession ce n'est pas l'origine
sociale c'est simplement d'aimer la
france est simplement de se retrouver
dans ces valeurs là si on ne s'y
retrouve pas je suis désolé il ya un
problème et pas ce qu'on fait eh bien il
faut avoir une politique migratoire il
faut avoir des quotas il faut avoir une
réforme profonde du droit d'asile il
faut reprendre tout à zéro il faut aussi
une école qui fasse aimer l'histoire
française notre histoire il faut en même
temps promouvoir ses valeurs
qui sont de belles valeurs qui sont pas
des valeurs du passé mais qui sont les
valeurs de notre avenir qu'on ne leur
vend nos enfants guillaume daudin de la
sp va donc vont nous rejoindre
maintenant pour évoquer la compétition à
l'ump un pour la présidence du parti
bien sûr et puis en vue de la primaire
de 2016 d'abord on va voir comment alain
juppé crée désormais la surprise sondage
après sondage samia de sheer
c'est un peu sa revanche alain juppé
l'homme qu'on disait fini en 2004 fait
aujourd'hui figure de favori pour la
primaire ump
les derniers sondages lui donnent 12
points d'avancé sur nicolas sarkozy
une course qui se joue pour l'instant
moins sur les programmes que sur la
personnalité et sur ce point alain juppé
a su changer son image d' homme austère
il est aujourd'hui dans une situation
dans laquelle il ne s'est jamais trouvé
dans sa vie politique en tout cas dans
sa vie politique nationale il roule pour
lui pour la première fois il peut être
lui-même et je pense que ça te d'hiver
c'est pour ça qu'il est à la fois claire
plus drôle probablement et plus naturels
autres mais c'est aussi et surtout le
style juppé qui séduit face à nicolas
sarkozy jugé hyperactif bling bling et
surtout trop clivant qu'alain juppé dans
le sentiment d'être calme poutre posée
d'avoir la stature d'homme d'état et de
donner le sentiment également face à une
france qui a le sentiment d'être
relativement divisés de pouvoir
rassembler assez fortement la société
française rassemblés et surtout élargir
au centre c'est l'autre clé du succès
juppé quand nicolas sarkozy séduit
davantage le noyau dur de l'ump avec
alain juppé on partage certains
engagements notamment sur les questions
écologiques depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
et
et de fait sur ce sujet là on est
absolument en phase après je n'ai pas à
juger au sein de l'ump qui sera
privilégiée par les uns ou par les
autres mais en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est qu'on a un vrai partage d'idées et
de valeurs sur les questions écologiques
et sur notre vision d'avenir de la
société si la montée en puissance
d'alain juppé fait de l'ombre à nicolas
sarkozy c'est aussi l'autre candidat
françois fillon qu'elle pénalise avant
qu'alain juppé monte en puissance le
duel annoncé c'était sarko et fillon
maintenant qu'ils aient eu cette montée
en puissance a dû annoncer sa sarkozy
juppé alors ces choses là peuvent encore
bouger mais la vraie difficulté pour
françois fillon à mon avis c'est que
françois fillon a pris un positionnement
très en pointe de thatchérisme à la
française ce positionnement est
minoritaire à l'intérieur même de la
droite mais françois fillon peut compter
sur le soutien d'une centaine de
parlementaires et nicolas sarkozy a
toujours la confiance des militants
mieux que personne alain juppé c'est que
les sondages peuvent s'inverser d'ici
2016 voilà guillaume
vos questions
bonsoir monsieur retailleau on va le
voir dans les secondes dans le précédent
sujet donc il ya un certain nombre de
sondages qui commença à pencher en
faveur d'alain juppé a montré une
progression de sa part si vous avez
l'impression voit aussi que il progresse
qu'il commence à être le la personnalité
numéro un à droite par ce numéro un je
ne sais pas mais il ya une progression
c'est clair dans les sondages est-ce que
vous souvenez à quel niveau et et
françois hollande au début de l'année
2011 à moins de 5% à 2% donc si vous
voulez c'est alors relativiser sondages
d'autant plus qu'il ya deux compétitions
la première compétition c'est la
compétition pour la présidence de l'ump
alain juppé ou françois fillon n'en sont
pas nicolas sarkozy en est puis ensuite
sur à l'autre compétition moi j'y suis
attaché les primaires qui devront
départager le candidat de droite et du
centre pour l'élection présidentielle de
2017 alors il ya un élément qui sur
lequel peut-être vous avez une analyse
c'est le retour de nicolas sarkozy brice
hortefeux a parlé d'un retour réussi
d'autres le voient peut-être un peu plus
raté qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez bon encore une fois c'est une
compétition pour la tête d'un parti
je l'imaginais pas moi dans cette
trajectoire là je l'imaginais plutôt sur
la trajectoire des primaires c'est
compliqué pour lancer c'est parce que je
dis en relief un des nos dires guaino
delà c'est compliqué et cetera et
effectivement je pense qu'il aurait pu
s'en passer il a choisi de le faire il
est parfaitement légitime et il a tous
ses atouts pour bien suivre conquérir la
présidence du parti voilà mais c'est pas
forcément en retour réussi en tout cas
mais en tout cas il est évident que
lorsque on est sur l'aventin lorsqu'on a
décidé de se retirer et complot pour
plonger en plus dans une compétition qui
oppose des hommes donc pour la bataille
pour la conquête d'un parti c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué c'est
une évidence voilà d'aucuns disent que
en dessous de 75 80 % la présidence de
l'ump ça sera déjà
ça sera déjà interprété comme un mauvais
résultat les interprétations moi je m'en
fiche non non je ne sais pas quel jeu
pas quel est le seuil je sais pas si
c'est 70 72 69 68 bon peu importe c'est
de cet ordre là en tout cas non je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas il est clair
que en tout cas ce qui ce qui est
positif pour le ps c'est une vraie
compétition une compétition d'abord pour
la présidence du parti et une
compétition aussi pour la primaire entre
nous c'est quand même positif que une
grande famille politique comme comme la
nôtre puisse aligner deux anciens
premiers ministres des hommes d'état
nicolas sarkozy ancien sans doute ancien
président de république je veux dire que
voilà abondance de biens ne nuit pas au
contraire finalement françois fillon
comme celui qu'a connu françois hollande
que ce monsieur 5% il a disparu des
écrans radar fillon aujourd'hui mais
vous pensez qu'il reviendra très fort
jusqu'à être le numéro un ce que je dis
c'est que les jeux sont toujours ouverts
moi je suis un homme de fidélité j'ai
une proximité à la fois affectif
géographique intellectuelle aussi avec
ce que représente françois fillon et le
jeu est très ouvert très franchement
encore une fois il ya une échéance qui
est le mois de décembre pour le parti et
puis ensuite il y aura d'autres
échéances pour les présidentielles et
donc les primaires donc vous vous avez
été dans votre histoire politique proche
de philippe de vie c'est françois fillon
maintenant est celle d'incarner une
certaine forme de thatchérisme à la
française est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ces deux lignes qui
sont assez compatibles ce thatchérisme
d'un côté est ce que ce que vous avez pu
représenter un moment samedi à gijon au
nord d'ailleurs le je récuse le mot de
thatchérisme je pense que quand on vit
en france aujourd'hui la france est au
bord du gouffre quand on vit dans un
pays où vous avez 50 7% de la dépense
publique plus évident du pib la richesse
vous êtes nécessairement pour plus
d'audace pour l'esprit d'entreprise vous
êtes pour plus de liberté vous êtes pour
dc pour desserrer tous les carcans et il
se positionne de façon claire et nette
parce que je pense encore une fois on
parlait tout à l'heure du gouvernement
ont parlé du budget je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sortir du cadre
les américains ont une expression est
dit out of the box mais si on reste dans
cadre on est mort et l'intérêt de
françois fillon c'est que il a creusé
son sillon il creuse son sillon il a des
propositions qui donne le là d'ailleurs
les propositions qu'il a annoncées en
matière d'économie en matière budgétaire
sont souvent des propositions qui sont
ensuite reprises par d'autres
challengers
mais justement il ya une femme il ya la
personnalité qui est importante vous
savez que dans la tradition un peu
gaullienne dans la tradition de la vème
république la présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un homme avec le peuple est
donc bien entendu que la personnalité
c'est quelque chose qui compte aussi
mémé pour moi qui ai toujours considéré
que la politique c'était d'abord des
idées des convictions voilà le projet
sera fondamental pour la france c est ce
que l'aune de cette rentrée politique on
n'a pas l'impression que c'est plutôt
françois fillon et nicolas sarkozy qui
alain juppé nicolas sarkozy qui vont à
l'encontre du peuple alors que françois
fillon est peut-être un peu écarté de ce
duel nous sommes mais non parce que
encore une fois trois ans c'est très
très long et que on est d'abord sur une
compétition pour le parti et ensuite y
aura les primaires tant que les jeux
vous verrez les jeux sont très très
ouvert c'est la raison pour laquelle je
rappelais les petits scores dans les
sondages de françois hollande un an et
demi avant avant tout cas pas de déprime
chez les fillonnistes non mais non pas
du tout parce que j'ai ce que j'ai l'air
déprimé
non mais cesser le combat je vais vous
dire c'est pas une question d'écurie la
france va mal moi j'aime la france
j'aime mon pays et je veux qu'ils se
portent mieux pas pas seulement pour moi
mais pour nos enfants pour les futures
générations et ça sera un choix qui sera
important je pense que si on loupe les
élections de 2017 le contrôle de la
situation nous échappera devenus des
musées vous pensez que le pouvoir sera
ramassé en 2010 est à moi je pense que
si ça compte a coûté alors là vraiment
m'a franchement franchement j'espère que
le suffrage universel pourra mettre la
gauche à l'écart aujourd'hui on va dans
le mur tout le monde le dit toulouse le
sens les français d'abord il souffre au
mieux ou au deuxième tour je comprends
pas bien votre nom ce que je veux dire
c'est que j'espère bien qu'il y aura une
alternance en 2017 qu'est-ce que ouvert
françois alors vous pouvez le dire est
ce qu il lui même peut le dire
parce qu'il peut le dire est ce que ses
ministres peuvent le dire pour ça qu'il
ya des zigzags décoiffe je disais tout à
l'heure donc non moi ce que j'espère
c'est que on aura une ligne qui sera une
ligne en rupture avec ce qui s'est fait
de la politique nationale depuis ces
dernières années la rupture c'est
peut-être aussi vous parliez justement
d'aider forme de personnalités de
comportement lionel tardy disait
aujourd'hui il me semble que on ne
pouvait pas débuter les finalistes aussi
parce qu'on ne peut pas forcément à la
fois ferme sur twitter très près
xenserver numérique faire des
conférences rémunéré comme le fait par
exemple aujourd'hui je crois nicolas
sarkozy à séoul et essayer de s'engager
au service de la france donc je t'en dit
non tu n'auras drame non pas le débat a
un problème de rémunération de
conférences et c'est vraiment pas le
sujet le sujet c'est la france et l'usep
tête d une représentation que se font
les français nicolas sarkozy de 2,2
quelqu'un voilà qui
ont franchement franchement c'est pas
sur ce sujet là que les français feront
leur choix
le choix sera de redresser la france ce
sera le rebond nationale c'est encore
temps ce sera très tard il y aura des
choix qui sont importants à faire sur
tous les sujets qu'on ait évoqué sur
l'indemnisation chômage sur les 35
heures
sur beaucoup d'autres sujets sur l'école
par exemple ils ce sont ses choix qui
devront décider du gagnant et du perdant
d'abord aux primaires puis ensuite à
l'élection présidentielle lors de
l'élection présidentielle on peut dire
un mot sur le premier tour avec la
présence de marine le pen bien sûr c'est
pour ça que je suis pour les primaires
les primaires qui ne sont d'ailleurs
plus contesté si c'était le cas ça n'est
plus maintenant le cas désormais les
primaires c'est quand même le ticket
pour celui qui les gagnera au deuxième
tour parce que avec ce que l'on connaît
désormais des scores du front national
s'il n'y a pas de primaire ce sera un
encouragement à une pluralité de
candidatures à droite et au centre pour
le premier tout est alors on est sûr
d'avoir non seulement marine le pen au
deuxième tour et peut-être aussi le
candidat de gauche si la droite se
présente de façon fractionnée et
éparpillé vous en tant que président du
groupe ump vous allez rester neutre vous
avez dit dans dentelle pour qu'elle le
scrutin pour celui de la présidence de
l'ue justement où j'ai pris j'ai pris un
engagement vous savez on est au sénat je
crois que la force du sénat c'est
l'indépendance et l'autonomie aussi bien
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif comme ceux
d'hier et ceux d'aujourd'hui que
vis-à-vis de notre famille il n'est pas
question je les dis que le groupe ump au
sénat se transforme en succursale soit
une courroie de transmission il y avait
des tentations j'ai atteint il ya il
doit y avoir effectivement une
coopération elle sera sans ambiguïté
elle sera franche active mais je suivrai
la ligne de l'indépendance et pour la
suivre je serai le garant de l'unité et
pour être le garant je me suis engagé
justement cette neutralité dans le
premier temps de l'élection du président
ce qui n'exclut pas qu'ensuite vous
puissiez exprimé une préférence pour la
primaire oui mais je ferai très très
attention je ferai très attention les
gens ne connaissent ils savent
l'infidélité je ferai très attention à
ne pas tiraillés le groupe encore une
fois si on veut avoir un sénat qui se
redresse il faut que le premier groupe
politique puisse être unis pour être
fort c'est la condition du redressement
aussi du bicamérisme bon il ya une
question qui divise dans le groupe
politique sélection du mariage pour tout
ça on peut être pas dans le groupe mais
en tout cas l'ump
certains sont pour un débat nicolas
sarkozy d'autres sont pour
l'abrogation pendant que laurent
wauquiez françois fillon si je me trompe
pas comme alain juppé n'envisage pas de
l'abroger une réécriture ils sont
prononcés pour une réécriture ça c'est
de la sémantique pour écrire faut
abroger moi je suis favorable à
l'abrogation voilà donc j'ai porté au
sénat la motion référendaire on pourrait
d'ailleurs soumettre aux français par
référendum un choix voilà je crois que
il faut avoir un immense respect pour
les êtres qui souhaite consacrer leur
amour on peut le faire avec union civile
on a différentes formules pour le faire
juridiquement en revanche le prime de la
filiation le problème de l'adoption des
bouches tôt ou tard on le voit
aujourd'hui sur la pma et sur la gpa il
n'en est pas question le groupe est pas
ce que dit le gouvernement il n'en est
pas question va t il il ya une
hypocrisie une hypocrisie sans nom 1 le
gouvernement ne fait pas appel de la
décision de la cour européenne devra de
l'homme de le gouvernement il ya encore
quelques semaines à 300 mètres de
l'assemblée ça fait la troisième fois en
un an et demi une société américaine
était en train de vente des services
pour louer le ventre de femme sans doute
nécessiteuses à des couples français
c'est interdit c'est inacceptable parce
que c'est la marchandisation du corps
c'est inacceptable juridiquement parce
que c'était interdit pourquoi pourquoi
madame taubira pourquoi le parquet ne
poursuit pas ces sociétés donc on est
mais bagnols trouver un avenir à ses
enfants qui naissent
par exemple pourquoi pourquoi des
sociétés américaines c'est la troisième
fois un peu de temps violent la loi en
france proposent les jeunes grecs non
non non c'est faux il propose avec comme
des bestiaux en présentant des femmes
vous choisissez blondes brunes et cetera
mais exactement comme des bestiaux est
ce que ça vous révoltent pas eh bien moi
ça me révolte et sur mon pays en tant
que la loi soit respectée justement la
question que je posais c'est on comprend
pas forcément quelle va être la position
l'ump en 2017 si jamais l arrivée au
pouvoir sur ce sujet abonnés ont eu très
clair moi je souhaite qu'il y ait une
abrogation qui est un référendum et qui
examine les couples
peut pas démarrer image et sûr et
récemment une exceptionnelle sera pas
rétroactif bien sûr ça ne sera pas
rétroactif le problème vous voulez c'est
exactement observé sous vous avec le
pacs les abeilles guigou des ja le pack
sera pas le mariage ensuite introduire
il ya le mariage mais il y aura pas la
paix règnera par la terreur le problème
c'est qu'au nom de l'égalité conçu comme
une stricte un strict égalitarisme on
voit bien que ce qu'ont les couples de
femmes les coupes des hommes le veulent
et ça nous entraîne très bien alors il
faut mettre il faut mettre des limites
c'est tout voilà je reviens d'un mot sur
les enfants puisque sur public sénat
jacques toubon le nouveau défenseur des
droits a expliqué qu'il fallait
effectivement offrir un cadre et un
statut aux enfants mais menées
illégalement au demeurant cadres et leur
donner des papiers une reconnaissance il
y un cadre jury à l'état civil oui mais
il y un cadre juridique les ceux qui
prétendent que aujourd'hui ces enfants
sont en dehors du droit se trompe il y à
un cadre maintenant alors leur zone des
papiers dont vont les retient laquelle
allait reconnaître et à 18 ans ils vont
ils choisiront d'être il n'y a pas de
souci ils ce sont à ces personnes là ces
jeunes enfants sont pas en dehors du roi
en revanche admettre et régularisés si
j'ose dire une infraction à la loi un
détournement de ce qu'on appelle de
l'ordre public moi je n'y suis pas
favorable corps pour être clair on il ya
une ligne on s'y tient voilà après on
peut d'abord fait 12 alité pour
l'abrogation on l'a compris on reviendra
d'ailleurs avec perrine sur certaines de
vos convictions et qui vous motive dans
ce débat ces accords bruno retailleau
merci guillaume puisqu'on va parler un
peu plus de vous maintenant également de
ce que vous comptez faire est ce que
vous proposez comme réforme pour le
sénat juste après ce portrait donc que
dresse sandra cerqueira
on le dit très attaché à sa terre
vendéenne sur les cinq hectares qui
entoure sa maison bruno retailleau
élèves une véritable petite basse cour
c'est un élu des territoires une carte
sur laquelle il a joué pour prendre la
tête de l'ump au sénat alors qu'il n'est
encarté que depuis deux ans un tour de
force pour cet inconnu du grand public
son objectif redorer l'image d'un sénat
mise à mal être fillonniste a aussi dû
jouer en sa faveur y avait véritable
volonté de nos collègues de conserver
l'indépendance du groupe au sénat et
c'est vrai que la candidature du
rothschild roger karoutchi a peut-être
pu apparaître comme étant trop liée à
l'élection interne à la tête de l'ump je
pense que ça a joué mais la volonté de
renouvellement a certainement été le
critère prépondérant jusque là bruno
retailleau a effectué sa carrière au mpf
le mouvement pour la france et dans
l'ombre de philippe de villiers qui en a
fait son bras droit au conseil général
de vendée un passé villiéristes qui lui
colle à la peau même si en 2009 c'est la
rupture avec son mentor philippe de
villiers refuse que bruno retailleau
intègre le gouvernement fillon c'était
pour lui quand même une histoire
d'honneur au moment où
le discours devenait trop extrémiste
bruno retailleau qui a voulu garder
justement à cette ligne de conduite et
cette objectivité a compris que il
fallait aussi que qu'ils puissent je
veux dire jouer sa propre mélodie
s'émanciper pour continuer raconté en
politique même chez les socialistes
bruno retailleau a le vent en poupe
certains lui prédisent même un destin
national
à l'intérieur de ma commission pendant
trois ans je trouve quelqu'un d'ouvert
et de compétent et de travailleurs avec
ça ou vous avez un bon profil le message
qui lui a été envoyé par le groupe ump
est une reconnaissance de ses
compétences anti mariage pour tous les
positions dites conservatrice du
sénateur de vendée dérange pour esther
benbassa la droite se radicalise au
sénat avec l'élection de bruno
retailleau des prises de position de
plus en plus à droite
qui vont un petit peu dans le sens de
plaire
à la droite
de marine le pen d'aller dans ce sens
plutôt que dans un sens les d'ouverture
et de compréhension ça m'inquiète mais
loin des sujets polémiques bruno
retailleau a choisi pour commencer de
s'attaquer à la fraude fiscale des
parlementaires un sujet plutôt
consensuel
écologistes le même regard
vous allez peut-être tentés d'essayer de
rassurer esther benbassa avec qui
parfois vous avez dit
mais c'est vrai alors déjà sur le nouvel
organigramme du sénat il ya une élection
qui a été constestée c'est celle des
sénateurs ump alain milon à la tête de
la commission des affaires sociales
alain millot qui avaient pris position
dans un rapport pour un encadrement de
la gpa en france est ce que vous êtes de
ceux qui contestent ses positions
d'onglets ce qu'il a toute sa place à la
tête de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat les plus sûres bien
sûr c'est un très bon spécialiste
notamment des questions sociales il a
montré d'ailleurs il ya eu qu'un seul
candidat il n'a pas été élu contre
quelqu'un d'autre c'était une des
commissions où il y avait un seul
candidat donc il ya pas eu d'élection
parce que ses collègues lui ont fait
confiance
voilà simplement alain milon sur un
serbe de questions peut avoir des
positions personnelles mais il y aura la
position du groupe qui très
majoritairement au moment du mariage
pour tous à 97 18 % a été clair et il
n'a pas souhaité voter le mariage pour
tous et tous je pense que là aussi ça ne
correspond pas peut-être à ce qu'on
attend de nous en termes de fermeture
cet arabe ce que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure mais il ya des positions qui
peuvent être parfois individuel chacun
sa liberté conscience chacun son
parcours personnel que je respecte
beaucoup en revanche dès lors qu'il faut
trancher il ya une cohérence et à unit
du groupe et puis voilà c'est tout il ya
aucun sujet j'ai vu que ça a été une
question débattue mais il n'y a pas de
ya pas de signal si j'ose dire avec
à la mi longue quitte donc un expérience
spécialisée des questions sociales par
ailleurs les médecins il connaît son
sujet sur toutes ces questions la gpa
pma les familles homosexuelles ou non
tout le monde se pose des questions y
compris l'église j'imagine que vous
suivez un peu ce qui se passe à rome
autour du pape françois le synode sur la
famille le compte rendu du rapport
d'étape montre une évolution de la part
de l'église qui insiste notamment en
matière de gps sur le droit des petits
droit qui prime sur celui des adultes la
réflexion l'église évoluer ce que ça va
dans le bon sens selon vous savez je
suis pas théologie donc je suis pas y si
ça peut vous rassurer quand même demandé
sa position sur des sujets théologie
maintenant moi je trouve que qui vous
intéressent ensuite je trouve que les
positions du pape françois vont dans le
bon sens je pense que la préférence
notamment pour les fragiles pour les
pauvres pour ceux qui sont blessés de la
vie qui avait aussi exprimé l'époque
jean paul 2 c'est important le fait
qu'ils puissent faire avancer les
positions moi je rejoins dans ses
réformes sociétales non moi je non je
trouve que c'est plutôt positif il
convoque un synode on en parle ce sera
tranché moi je trouve que au contraire
je trouve c'est une façon plutôt moderne
et généreuse de conduire
au divorce et les questions qui divisent
oui mais moi ça moi c'est franchement ça
ne choque pas encore une fois lorsqu'on
est amené je pense qu'il ya il ya deux
choses je crois qu'il faut respecter
infiniment chaque être humain quel que
soit son choix quel que soit son
inclinaison ces voix là il ya aucun
sujet de ce point de vue là après quand
on est responsable public comme moi on
doit prendre on fait des choix il
m'arrive pour tous pour moi ça posait
cette question de la filiation
d'adoption qui devait tout ou tard
débouché sur la gpa la pma voilà c'est
tout après chacun justement exprime ses
convictions mais moi je trouve que ce
que souhaitent les français se sont pas
des hommes politiques hors sol sans
conviction c'est qu'on ait
l'intelligence d'affirmer des
convictions tout en respectant toujours
les adversaires les personnes c'est
toujours été mon cas voilà on peut avoir
une sorte de fermeté dans la conviction
et
de respect envers goût quand on l'entend
connaissent beaucoup de thé non je parle
mais je suis coûté mal de non moi je
suis je suis ouvert voilà
franchement je ne m'amuse pas ce genre
de choses je pense que c'est le degré
zéro de la politique donc je préfère
débattre sur des arguments plutôt que de
condamner tel ou tel en fonction de ses
positions je crois que on est dans une
démocratie ce qui est important c'est
que chacun puisse argumenté est-ce que
ici au sénat dans tous les débats qu'on
a pu avoir on a pu me faire le reproche
de ne pas argumenter mes positions je
pense pas que je passe pour quelqu'un
qui ne sache pas argumenter ses
positions alors maintenant vous allez
argumenté sur ce que vous voulez faire à
la tête du groupe ump ici au sénat vous
entendez un carnet avec d'autres le
renouveau le nouveau sénat alors c'est
vrai qu'après des semaines de senna
bashing avant les élections sénatoriales
la crédibilité voire même parfois la
légitimité de la haute assemblée a été
entamée quelles réformes vous voulez
faire très rapidement ici au sénat pour
redorer l'image de la haute assemblée
pour le sauver oui je veux moi je pense
que on célèbre le 100e anniversaire vous
savez de la guerre 14-18 et et après
valérie avait eu cette phrase en disant
voilà nous savons désormais que les
civilisations sont mortelles et bien les
institutions sont aussi mortelle
simplement ce que je veux dire aux
français ce qu'ils nous écoutent
peut-être à l'instant c'est que dans un
moment difficile que traverse la france
il ya une chose qui tient ses les
institutions qu'à fonder général de
gaulle de la vème république est ce que
je veux dire c'est que le bicamérisme
c'est fondamental pourquoi c'est
fondamental parce que c'est une réponse
je trouve à deux mots qui sont
importants on légifère trop sous
l'émotion qu'elle en soit disait que le
sénat c'est le recul c'est le temps de
la réflexion on en a besoin pour avoir
moins de lois et des lois mieux fait et
ensuite on a besoin d'un territoire
l'histoire quand on voit tous les
gouvernements qui utilisent de plus en
plus les prévenir et bien c'était rien
eh bien c'était supprimer le sénat
qu'est-ce qui se passera une seule
lecture avec l'assemblée nationale sous
l'émotion sous la pression médiatique
une lecture politicienne tandis qu' il y
aura plus de loi beaucoup plus de loi
beaucoup plus mal fait et ensuite le
deuxième avantage du sénat france des
territoires or un des problèmes français
c'est la fracture territoriale
on voit bien qu'il ya deux france qui
sont en train de diverger la france
connectée à la mondialisation et la
france des invisibles des souliers mais
je pense que le sénat peut rapprocher
ces deux france la voilà c'est pour ça
que je crois que senna est important il
est moderne d'avancé sur l'intérêt du
bicamérisme que nous partons jaune a
effectivement beaucoup ici mais sur les
réformes
concrètement à écouter première chose
j'ai plaidé pour la carte du
rajeunissement du renouvellement je
pense commencer vous avec 100 g père et
aussi pour la carte du la féminisation
par exemple un un des deux postes qui
nous était celle de l'ump je les réserve
est pour une femme isabelle debré a été
brillamment élu es et j'en félicite sa
main sur moi sénateurs oui alors
les réformes je pense que il faut que
ces nains se réforme notamment un
certain nombre il faut plus de
transparence plus édité il ya la réserve
parlementaire sur les comptes des
groupes politiques on sait qu'il ya eu
des problèmes autour de certains comptes
de l'uimm eh bien je pense que la
certification des comptes c'est une
exigence absolument la misère parlement
la vézère sans le gentil non je pense
que les communes et petite commune au
moment où l'état est en train de baisser
ses notations en ont besoin simplement
il faut pas qu'il ait une différence de
traitement ne soit pas expliqué donc il
faut la transparence et il faut en même
temps les quitter et je m'appliquerai
avant la fin d'année à faire avec gérard
larcher cette réforme là donc ce sont
des choses concrètes il faut aussi
sortir le sénat de paris beaucoup plus
souvent paris donc comment voyez vous
verrez
sortir et c'est notre pari et vous savez
oui -2 -2 grand messe par exemple les
assises de la ruralité journée il ya
deux ans les états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale des grand messes
qui paient cher et finissent par quoi
pas par rien du tout bien je pense qu'on
doit aller sur le terrain quand il est
le drame xynthia un exemple on a créé
avec gérard larcher une mission
d'information il y avait aussi une
mission de députés les sénateurs se sont
rendus les premiers sur le terrain et je
vous assure qu'on a fait un excellent
travail eh bien il faut être il faut que
senna soit en prise avec le quotidien en
même temps tout en ayant cette ce recul
cette hauteur de vue c'est fondamental
bruno retailleau qu'est ce qui vous
reste de votre aventure aux côtés de
philippe de villiers rodez vous souvenir
du genou bien sûr j'étais 25 ans metteur
en scène tout à fait bénévole même et
c'est une grande réussite française
qu'il faut saluer voilà chez c'est tout
ça fait partie ça fait penser au langage
il ya eu des divergences avec la mine en
fait il ya eu des divergences bien avant
2009 voilà
etc voilà c'est ce qui m'a écarté
progressivement de philippe de villiers
la mise en scène qui est maintenant
vendu en russie avec des déclarations
parfois un peu surprenante de philippe
de villiers sur poutine j'échangerais
volontiers hollande plus sarkozy contre
poutine fait partie des choses qui m'ont
c'est ce qui vous ont séparés voilà sept
cette expression là est en elle-même une
partie de l'explication
dernière question peut-être autour de
journal guérini qui a été réélu
confortablement ici cemac est ce que
vous inspire ce spectacle de ce sénateur
confortablement donc réélu et devant la
justice dix jours après il aura rendre
des comptes devant la justice moi je
pense que la présomption d'innocence
vaut pour tout le monde les élus sont
pas au dessus des lois les élus ne sont
pas en dessous des lois c'est tout il ya
une élection elle et j'imagine
démocratique s'est déroulé n'est pas
contestée est donc désormais c'est le
temps de la justice il faut que la
justice aille à son terme je pense que
je suis un partisan des institutions
fortes l'asus eee la justice et notre
institution c'est notre bien commun mais
il faut faire attention de ne pas juger
avant les juges c'est le juge qui doit
vous voulez monsieur propre que vous
l'avez plus loin que les mesures de
transparence qui ont été annoncées par
le chef de l'état a alimenté d'ailleurs
pour
leur rapport des parlementaires à leur
dossier fiscal et que sandra cerqueira
la bande jamais vain mot bien sûr un mot
nous avons déposé j'ai déposé plusieurs
sénateurs de l'ump avec moi une
proposition de loi sur la sphère
thévenoud parce qu'il en a marre vous
savez bien qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un
parlementaire qui se trouve pris sous
les feux des projecteurs pour avoir
commis non pas des indélicatesses
mais les fautes extrêmement grave ça
rejaillit sur nos institutions sur nous
mêmes j'entendais des déclarations du
président de la réserve certificat
et bien moi j'ai versé cette proposition
de loi j'en ai marre des déclarations je
souhaite qu'on avance donc les choses
sont très simples il faudra indiquer sur
l'honneur qui a pas de soucis ce sera
transmis à la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie politique qui
transmettra s'il ya un problème je pense
que on vote la loi on voit la loi de
finances qu'on vote l'impôt la moindre
des choses c'est de d'être vis-à-vis de
cette norme qui concerne tous les
français en parfaite régularité il
s'agit pas d'une étourderie c'est
vraiment quand il ya un écart important
offrant simplement déclarations que j'ai
pensé à monsieur balkany aussi à je
pense à tous ceux qui ne respectent pas
dans des conditions exorbitantes les
déclarations est en réalité le droit
commun voilà fabien merci monsieur
retailleau merci devrait être avec mercy
perrine bonsoir à tous et à très vite